yo speaking of
uh three episodes in a row of the pauls
i know it's like i don't want to talk
about them anymore i don't yeah and
every single time the crypto scams is
just you know you know and and actually
the steph curry tweet being like oh i'm
new to crypto like what should i get
into it's so cool that once you hit a
certain level level of celebrity
everyone just wants to try to make you
more money click on the steph curry one
oh yeah okay i see just getting started
in the crypto game okay wait what's the
top reply this has got to be the
by telco buy telcoin 50 hours of
homework
oh geez
carry on time gary
on time gary he's like
well you should first off you should cut
off your own yeah
steph i want you to picture your family
in a cement mixer
i'd like you to give yourself paper cuts
between your toes
imagine we took all your dogs and put
them in a small cement mixer you're the
dink doink i thought that this tweet
meant like i'm just getting started on
my own crypto game yeah because he
bought an nft so i thought he's like
he's like now in the board ape yacht
club so i thought he was kind of like
tuned in on what's been going on so i
thought he was pulling a logan
because logan's new thing is cryptozoo
which is an nft game but the game hasn't
been released yet and it's got adobe
stock images yeah so he tweeted and he
was like hey i've been waiting for this
moment for seven months like my crypto
game is finally here
and it's not yeah first of all and
second of all it's like apparently
that's seven months of development all
they did is take stock animals stock
images of animals sorry and photoshop
them to be part another animal what's
even better is it's adobe stock so you
get all that stuff with a monthly fee so
so you can just find that [ __ ] in
photoshop yeah it's not even like he
like
went and paid for individual uses on
that he's got like his editor has like a
50 a month creative cloud
add-on subscription and in photoshop
he just takes these images that are
readily of it like it is hysterical that
anyone thinks this dude is a nice guy
and he made one point
nine million dollars i think on this
yeah 1.9 million in one day like on on
monday or something like that selling
you stock images
you're a clown like you're a clown if
you if you think just like it's it's
baffling
how does nobody see that this is just
robbery yeah that dinked on
like
oh his other nft project with all the
you know super saiyan cards logan paul
is just fortnite
just selling skins and bogus [ __ ] and
it's all these like 10 year olds who are
just like swiping their parents card dad
can you make a coin base account i want
to buy this stuff the [ __ ] is coinbase
i want to buy this adobe stock from paul
yeah it costs four thousand dollars
what the [ __ ] is the four thousand
dollars uh no it's not dad okay it's one
eighth
okay i don't know what u.s dollars are
oh my god dude so funny like one of
these kids grows up and in 20 years he
becomes a designer yeah and he's
searching adobe stock because adobe
doesn't update word [ __ ] yeah you know
over 20 years and he's gonna type in
penguin he's gonna be like wait
wait a second well i recognize that
he's gonna have an existential crisis i
really
burned my my dad's college savings for
me to buy this [ __ ] picture with a
long nose
it's kryptos dude dude it's fun it's not
a panda
it's an elephanta
it's not a penguin
it's a
sanguine
shark penguin penguin
it's a park yeah it's a park like who
who would ever thought
that
you know
the the the two dudes from vine would
grow up to do
modern penny stocks
like
okay so they haven't hatched yet yeah no
but go back
[ __ ] like blow up that picture of the
[ __ ] panda cat
[ __ ] elephant with butterfly here is
you kidding me people ask me what it's
like to be on shrooms it's like this
yeah
hey yo that [ __ ] cat candle cat panda
get that thing honestly i gotta be
honest it's cute as hell
no it's not
it's cute as hell dude
it looks like one of those books from
urban outfitters that's like that you
put like your finger into and it's like
the tiny book about the penis or
something like you know what i'm talking
about no it has like a little like sock
puppet in the middle that you put your
two fingers through and it's like you
have to like read a story
yeah niche ref sorry what is that dude
the pug duck the [ __ ] bug chick yeah
punch duck
yeah what is that
what the [ __ ]
who would ever even think about
combining those two animals it this
looks like a really
bad like gas station calendar and the
sad part is one of you bozos is gonna
look at this and go
well i mean he does have a big audience
maybe if i just get in now and i can
sell just like really quickly
i could make a little money on this
you will not
i want to buy 10.
how much are they
can we scroll or 0.3 right now oh yeah
it says it right there you'd be crazy
not to get in right now
what's the theory i'm at as of now
oh it's down 10 percent today man
there's like a mini crypto crash today
i don't know what the [ __ ] is happening
but point two down ten percent crypto is
crashing surprise
yeah
it's all right it'll it just goes
because of cryptozoo that's why yeah
yeah yeah dude it's it's it's only a
thousand dollars right now what for
you potentially might get the pug duck
can you imagine how rare that thing's
gonna be yeah the pug duck yeah oh dude
no one's gonna have that yeah
can you imagine in 10 years when you can
show your friends in vr i have the logan
paul pug duck they're gonna go oh [ __ ] i
wanted that one have the puck yeah yeah
great
i was thinking how do you combine the
two you have dog
you have doug dude you have do pug it's
bruce
the pug the bug
you have to pug you have you have paguck
wait you got to put guck 9000 you got
the logan paul pagan
we should just take
like parody images of great art and sell
that yeah you know like the moaning lisa
and it's her just like oh yeah yeah yeah
hit it
oh i got two going at the same time now
this is the this is the serum that turns
it into the clb moaning lisa
keep going
[Music]
um picasso
um is that what you're about to say
pascordo it could be um
picoxo picoxo
[Music]
van go to the polls
how about the salvador daldes fabson
pollock
the jackson pollock painting is what
it's all come the fabsom pollock
rendition of the guck
that no that should that should be what
we do we just copy and paste this all
[ __ ]
yo this is the sequel to crypto zoo you
might get the paguck too
[Laughter]
it's a pug with a duck bill
the [ __ ] beak
we should make this but all the
pictures are gifs yeah or they're svgs
whatever one like has sound oh yeah
little movies and all the animals are
going kill me
you kill me
i'm in so much pain kill me oh these are
cute you'll hover over
why
we release a serum and it just kills the
animal
and you get a second nft of the animal
just
scarred with acid and dead and decaying
you're like
whoa
kind of dark it's cryptozoo too
buy nfts of your favorite tick-tockers
taylor holder and josh richardson
just
down the middle stitch together
[ __ ] brain glued together
both of them fighting for a majority of
the break get him out of me
josh on one side i don't want to be a
boxer
it hurts